Gold I'm doing one more acting and I'm
done
Ruby fellow I'm very busy of other
things to do oh it's nice sneaky
question in honor of season five we have
a fast five round of questions is this
is right come for I know I know the only
thing we're gonna games at Lee an idea
who does add soul of the most on set me
well yeah probably take it woods
absolute love me if I ever got a chance
but anytime the cat is on set cat goes
to the cat no cat the cat is a cat so
the cat loves nobody more than he loves
himself let's be honest I can't tolerate
its cat the most no the cat gets that
ratted that's right we gotta stuff what
does baby Jamie love the most
yeah probably all love Katrina most and
he's not true oh they're so sweet but
they really that age is so difficult
like well they definitely Sam doesn't
love them the most so cute oh it's just
funny yeah Matthew and Andrew sort of
ended up becoming our main jammies
Lippert and they are just the cutest and
sweetest little boys I have a video of
them the actor well one of the twins he
plays Jamie telling Richard awfully into
trouble from most of the junior I need
you to really I'm really yeah when we're
allowed to show Jamie as well we'll put
it out we need to so fear and there's
another one well there was this scene a
pro can talk about this scene but it
comes off to meet with you he has to
shout at him in the heart of the tick's
I keep saying I'm sorry I'm really sorry
we man it's okay it's not real and I had
to do it again I'm like oh my god could
me not do it say anymore
I need us destroy a fellow but like you
know they're two and a half and you get
them to do it once brilliantly and then
they're like we're bored
we've adopted their catchphrase which is
I'm doing one more acting and I'm done
I'm done no do one more acting
I'm very busy you have other things to
do so yeah person who has been wielding
their producer power or more samer
Katrina gold what no I think I mean I
know it's been a process to to be to be
involved more and to have a say and you
know I think we would like to do a lot
more oh nice question that imagine
Katrina
she seems she likes to be very involved
and putting making effects your things
have gone in the right direction but
those two times didn't use doing it
quietly other great team and they kind
of like good cop bad cop and they go in
it together so I feel like but they are
all very much for the betterment or for
sure there was a lot of learning and
observing and you know I think it's a
new role for both of us and I think it's
one that we take very seriously
um and we came on sort of late into the
process when when we when we sort of got
that role and so we've been doing our
best to sort of see where we can be the
most helpful and and I think towards the
end of the season we definitely I think
found our feet feet with that role a bit
more and hopefully coming into this next
season as well it will sort of continue
to expand and it's important to have
that sort of collaboration and that
influence and you know I think you know
there's the scripts and the storyline we
definitely had an influence there and
also being part of you know the
production meetings just seeing all the
work that goes into it no I think we're
a lot more educated as well which of
your co-stars have you been most
impressed by in season five
you've brought the most intense pain
me well I think you know we sort of
started off in this show as The Young
Ones and now we are definitely not the
young ones were sort of the the old
fogies they still are the young ones you
know there's a lot of aging makeup and
they still look better than we do now so
you know but it's been beautiful to
watch all of our younger actors you know
whether it's Sophie or a Richard or John
Bell or Lauren Lyle horses are you know
they've all our world has expanded you
know it used to sort of very much be
told through Claire's eyes and Jamie's
eyes and now that we've expanded the
world all of their storylines have sort
of opened up and become stronger and
it's been great to watch them all
blossom and I think you know keep us on
our toes drawing part of Island has
always been the cost I think and the
ensemble and you know we were sad to see
ever leave up to season one you know
this core group of Highlanders but I
think now we've got a really amazing
group of really amazing cast together
and but even our day players or smaller
characters that come in we have some
amazing ones this season which episode
of season five was your favorite to film
and why my favorite episode in terms of
for me in terms of I think performance
and walk and I think perhaps with a
trolli that was really really more so
the kids are really challenged in
episode my favorite apps with in terms
of how much fun we had it's probably I
think - I think mine was probably 12
because it was the most challenging for
me and it's probably the riskiest that
we've done I haven't actually seen it
yet so we'll see if that was a
successful risk or not
but it was definitely the the sort of
most challenging storyline that I had
been given this season and it was tough
but it was it was rewarding you think
yeah I agree I think it's probably the
strongest finale we've done I think for
me you know in a weird way because it's
it's a hard episode to watch but episode
10 is storyline why is this a really
strong gap we phoned in a nice location
and it just takes a turn that you just
don't expect so yeah can that be
interesting one for fence and for me I
think episode seven
sort of the culmination of one of my
storylines was fun - yeah
some gave a little bit a little bit more
than that I didn't try and you try
[Music]